today on the mat wall show democrats who
sat back and cheered while millions of
americans were impacted by rioting all
summer
spent last night on the house floor
tearfully describing their own trauma
from a riot in which none of them were
harmed
it's kind of a group therapy session and
a cynical and disgusting display as well
so we'll talk about that also five
headlines including the white house
declaring that even after you get the
vaccine
you still need to wear a mask so what's
the point of the vaccine then and in our
daily cancellation we'll discuss the
resurgent career
of nick cannon who got his job back
after calling white people sub-human
savages what does that tell us about the
nature of privilege in america plus
i'll read some of my youtube comments
all of that and much more today on the
matt wall show
[Applause]
before we really get started today i
want to tell you about uh express
vpn listen there really is no reason why
you shouldn't have a vpn there's no
reason i dare you to give me one
reason why you don't have one you can't
you can't you can't you just can't do it
there's never been a more important time
to protect your internet activity
uh than right now if you're gonna do it
now is the time that's why i urge you to
get expressvpn everything you search for
watch or click
online can be tracked by the big tech
companies they can match
your activity to your true identity
using your your device's unique ip
address
they can use this to invade your privacy
which you have a right to when i switch
on expressvpn with my computer or phone
my ip address is masked by a secure vpn
server which makes it harder for the
websites to identify me
plus the other great thing is that you
can use expressvpn on up to five devices
simultaneously
i've got it on all my devices so
multiple users on your network
can stay safe with a single subscription
what i like most is how easy it is to
use
if it were not easy to do i wouldn't be
able to do it
but uh for me all i got to do and all
you would have to do is just take one
click
and you protect all your devices it's
that simple and then you're giving
yourself that little bit of protection
that you deserve not a little bit but
quite a significant amount of protection
from the big tech companies who are
trying to invade your privacy
and have no right to do it so stop
handing over your data to big tech
companies go with the vpn that i trust
for online protection
visit expressvpn walsh to get three
months free on a one-year package that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com walsh to get three
months
free go to expressvpn.comwalsh right now
to learn more so last night in what
somehow managed to be
one of the most sickeningly cynical and
fraudulent displays we have ever seen
on the floor of congress and i
understand what a statement that is
a group of democratic representatives
decided to hold a group therapy session
as the lockdowns continue to [ __ ]
american businesses millions of our
citizens face
financial ruin and our nation faces a
host of crises from multiple fronts the
democrats
still carved out some time to talk about
their feelings
their favorite subject after all this
special house hearing was requested by
alexandria casa cortez whose own
cinematic tale of narrowly avoiding
death at the hands of right-wing
assassins took a major hit when it was
revealed that
the riot was happening in an entirely
different building from the one she was
in
nonetheless cortez was given more time
and space
on the taxpayer's dime in this case to
spin her yarn
so here she is introducing the evening's
program while
unabashedly labeling herself and her
colleagues as
survivors listen less than 29 days later
with little to no accountability for the
bloodshed and trauma of the sixth
some are already demanding that we move
on
or worse attempting to minimize
discredit
or belittle the accounts of survivors
in doing so they not only further harm
those who were there that day
and provide cover for those responsible
but they also send a tremendously
damaging message
to survivors of trauma all across this
country
survivors yeah aoc is as much a survivor
of this riot as i am
she was never in any direct danger she
was never confronted by any mob
she did not survive anything except in
the general sense of having made it
through another day without dying in the
sense that we're all survivors
by virtue of the fact that we're all
still currently alive if that's what she
means then fine
you know i'll wear the label too i'm a
survivor someone cue the beyonce song
now aoc was joined in this spectacle by
such squad luminaries as
corey bush and rashida talib the former
vacillated between openly weeping and
boldly declaring that she would have
personally whooped the asses of any
rioters who tried to
cost her so here she is making that
claim
madam speaker st louis and i rise to
reflect
on how our office experienced the white
supremacist attack
on our nation's capital on january the
6th
everybody is everybody's experiences are
different
and everybody's experiences must be
validated
so i remember sitting in the office with
my
team and just thinking to myself
i feel like i'm back at this very minute
i feel like i'm back
i feel like this was one of the days out
there on the streets when the white
supremacists would show up and start
shooting at us
this is one of the days when the police
will ambush us from behind
from behind trees and from behind
buildings and all of a sudden now we're
on the ground
being brutalized it felt like one of
those days and i just remember taking a
second thinking
if they touch these doors if they hit
these doors the way they hit that door
if they hit these doors
and come anywhere near my staff
and i'm just going to be real honest
about it my thought process was
we banging to the end i'm not letting
them take out my people
and you're not taking me out we've come
too far
yeah okay corey you're about to go full
kill bill i'm sure
had the katana ready and everything uh
now and she says
it took her back to the days of white
supremacist shooting at her when were
those days exactly what what is she
referring to that's a that's a headline
i'd like to know what what
happened she says that when they were
shooting at us apparently this is
something that happened to her
i'm not aware of that story notice too
she casually labels the rioters
white supremacists as she has from the
beginning this isn't very interesting as
she thinks everything is white supremacy
she would probably label a
literal jar of mayonnaise a white
supremacist but even so
it bears repeating that there's no
evidence and never was any evidence that
anything that happened on january 6
was at all racially motivated
for her part rashida talib could barely
speak
through her tears so overcome with
emotion
even though she wasn't even in dc on the
day of the riot
let's listen to that so what happened on
january 6th
all i could do was thank allah that i
wasn't here
i felt overwhelming relief and i feel
bad for
alexandria so many of my colleagues that
were here but as i saw it
i thought to myself thank god i am not
there
i saw the images that they didn't get to
see until later
my team and i decided at that point we'd
keep the death threats away
we try to report them document them to
keep them away from me
because it just paralyzed me and all i
wanted to do
was come here and serve the people
that raised me now she mentions earlier
in her speech
the death threats that she's gotten
during her career which have nothing to
do with the riot
but death threats to a congresswoman or
to anyone else or horrible
um i can tell you that i know that from
experience i myself had
had plenty of them i've gotten messages
plenty of messages
saying terrible things about not just me
but my wife and my children
i've had violence threatened against
against my kids
it's very upsetting to endure something
like that i know from experience
and the people who make these kinds of
threats or send these kinds of emails
are vile filth the lowest of the low
the point simply is that this happens to
anyone in the public eye as a
consequence not of systemic racism or
anything like that but of living in such
a tribalized society
another consequence of living in a
tribalized society ironically
is this display on the house floor this
is political stage craft
disguised as raw human emotion
for proof of that if you need it here
finally is representative dean
phillips in what was hailed as a moving
and powerful speech
but what was really one of the most
shamelessly cynical diatribes we have
ever heard in such a forum here it is
we know what it feels like searching for
something anything
with which to defend ourselves and
realizing
a pencil is about all we had
and we know what it feels like thinking
that it's a real
possibility that we would not see our
families and loved ones
again we won't forget
we won't forget but i'm not here this
evening
to seek sympathy or just to tell my
story
rather to make a public apology
for recognizing that we were sitting
ducks in this room as the chamber was
about to be breached
i screamed to my colleagues to follow me
to follow me across the aisle to the
republican side of the chamber
so that we could blend in
so that we could blend in for i felt
that the insurrectionists who were
trying to break down the doors
right here would spare us if they simply
mistook us
for republicans
but within moments i recognized that
blending
in was not an option available
to my colleagues of color
so i'm here tonight to say to my
brothers and sisters
in congress and all around our country
i'm sorry i'm sorry
give me a break dude i mean it's really
quite brilliant
if also completely dishonorable and
disgusting he implicates all of his
republican colleagues in the riot
positions the right as somehow racially
motivated
and pretends to humble himself while at
the same time engaging in naked
self-aggrandizement
all in the span of 90 seconds it was the
whole thing was the whole show the whole
therapy session was in some ways a
master class
for those who are utterly soulless and
care for nothing but power
now if you're not in that category
though you will be revolted by the
display
especially when you consider that these
very same people
did not care to hear the stories of
trauma from their own
constituents who lived through much
worse much more damaging much more
deadly rioting sustained for a much
longer period of time
yes i'll say it again i'll say it a
thousand times the rioting that happened
in our cities
was much much much worse
than this and the fact that this
happened to politicians
does not make it worse unless you
believe that politicians
are more worthy or worth more have more
value
than just regular citizens i don't
believe that
our members of congress endured an
unpleasant few hours one afternoon
i admit that none of them were ever
harmed in any way
afterwards they were flanked by national
guard fortified behind protective
barriers
the world cared about what they went
through the system responded forcefully
because after all these are these people
are the system
and the people responsible are being
hunted down and hit with every possible
criminal charge
okay so that's been their experience for
advoca average americans though
in towns like kenosha minneapolis
atlanta
any of the hundreds of other cities for
them portland seattle
it's been quite different in many cases
their neighborhoods are still in ruins
and nobody cares nobody's talking about
it the people responsible have not faced
justice
if they were arrested at all their
charges were dropped
i mean they went through weeks and weeks
and weeks of chaos violence and
destruction and when it ended
nobody helped them pick up the pieces
nobody's bringing them up on the house
floor to shed their tears under the
spotlight
they suffer alone and they are forgotten
even the people who are ostensibly on
their side or too cowardly
or too stupid to really help after all
the republicans could have done
what the democrats just did they could
still do it
they could have brought the victims of
blm rioting to congress
and set aside an hour or more for them
to speak and tell their stories
to reveal their lived experience
or republicans are too incompetent or
else disinterested or else plain dumb
to do something like that and so the
very people who normalized rioting and
cheered it on and created the situation
that we now are in
get to make themselves the victims of it
talk about privilege what we saw on the
floor of the house last night
that's it that's what privilege looks
like
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know living in nashville is great
we're enjoying it but one thing is
living close to a city i find myself
taking uber um a lot more than i than i
did before
and the the bad thing about that is i
get carsick and so i'm dealing with car
sickness
quite often and you know if you if you
have to deal with nausea for any reason
on a chronic basis
um it can it could really be tough it's
extremely uncomfortable it could be even
worse than uncomfortable sometimes
which is why i solve my problems with
relief band relief band is the number
one fda cleared
anti-nausea wristband that's been
clinically proven to quickly relieve and
effectively prevent
nausea and vomiting associated with
motion sickness anxiety migraine
hangover
morning sickness chemotherapy and so
much more the product is 100 drug-free
it's non-drowsy so it's better than
you know if you're on a car long car
ride you're feeling car sick maybe you
stop at the gas station get one of those
uh one of those uh anti-nausea
medications from a gas station somewhere
the problem is that um
these make you drowsy and you know you
probably want to be able to stay awake
for the day especially if you're driving
this is zero side effects non-drowsy the
technology was originally developed over
20 years ago in hospitals to relieve
nausea from patients
but now through relief band it's
available to the masses so what you got
to do
this new year if you want to ensure
nausea is never the reason to miss out
on life's important moments right
now relief band has an exclusive offer
just for matt walsh listeners
if you go to reliefband.com and use
promo code walsh you'll receive 20
off plus free shipping and no questions
asked 30 day money back guarantee
so head to r r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d.com
reliefband.com and use promo code walsh
for 20
off well the first piece of news not not
our first headline but i i just want to
mention that um
david hogg anti-gun activist
is apparently starting his own pillow
company to compete with my pillow
and mike lindell so he's gonna start up
he's gonna start a liberal he's gonna
start a leftist
pillow company and it really in some
ways this strikes me as the most leftist
thing in the world
to make a pillow company out of spite
he's gonna be angrily just stitching
pillows together i'm gonna get these
people
take this here's a pillow for you
um but it's good because you know uh
it's good that now pillows are
tribalized next i think we need our bed
sheets
and our blankets to be political
statements
uh i i think it's great we i i can't
wait till we're at a point
where every item in our house and
everything we eat
and everything we wear is a form of
political branding
you can wear your you can wear your uh
your liberal socks or your conservative
socks
you could drink liberal water or
conservative water
that's where we're headed it's great
because this is how you form
a healthy and happy society isn't it
all right number one from the daily wire
says a well-known emergency doctor who's
been promoted by the biden white house
said thursday that folks who did not
wear masks to a market in florida we
played that video for you the
cnbc shop smith was very scandalized
because people in florida at a grocery
store
weren't wearing a mask and he couldn't
just mind his own damn business so he
did a whole story about it and
everything
well this doctor said that in reference
to those people
he said that um they should be denied
vaccinations against cove 19 adding
let them die that's a great thing to
hear from a doctor isn't it
let them die in a now deleted post dr
cleven gilman captioned a video of the
masculist florida market goers saying
naples florida let them die
i'm so tired of these people no vaccine
for y'all
and then he continued i'm working in the
covet icu tonight i'm so tired of giving
200
while others in the u.s can't even help
by simply wearing a mask my spirits are
high
we'll get through this pandemic together
i'll keep doing my part until we're all
vaccinated
and then eventually took it down and
deleted it is this is what he says when
his spirits are high
let them die okay if that's him with his
spirits high i would hate to see this
guy when he's pissed off
especially if he's my doctor
you know this this whole thing um
i mean even even if you believe that you
know not wearing a mask is this this
terribly reckless thing and uh and all
of that
and if you get sick you brought it on
yourself and
it's very common to hear this now
usually you don't hear it quite so
explicitly from doctors
saying let them die but at least the
peanut gallery on twitter and elsewhere
they've been saying this for months
but if you don't wear a mask then you
should get medical treatment but
that's you notice these people they
would never apply that philosophy
in any other context
like what about someone who is morbidly
obese because of their terrible eating
habits
and then has heart disease would we say
let him die you did in many ways bring
that on yourself
uh what about someone who gets an std
because they're
you know going out to a bar well i guess
we're not doing that anymore but
someone who meets a different person on
tinder every week ends up with std
a consequence we what we all knew would
uh
anyone knew what would come and would we
say let them die or just let them suffer
now so if you're at least if you're
gonna if you're going to take this
position
that allegedly reckless behavior
means that you do not deserve medical
treatment for the consequences of that
behavior
then at least have the guts and the
intellectual consistency
to go all the way with it i wouldn't
agree but at least in that case i would
respect your consistency
okay number two the war between the
mayor of chicago and the teachers union
is uh is heating up and i have to say
i'm enjoying it or i would enjoy it
if not for the fact that the kids are
being hurt by this so if not for that
i would enjoy it but i don't here's
mayor lightfoot
taking it up to another level against
the teachers union watch
are safe and we all know that to be true
based upon our actual in-person
experience and let me remind you
of the over 100 million dollars
in mitigations that cps has invested in
our schools
to make them safe they included
ventilation testing house screening
face coverings enhanced cleaning and
other in-school
safety measures and as the expression
goes
the proof is in the pudding cps had
three weeks of successful
implementation of these mitigation plans
in our schools
that was until the ctu blew up that
success
and created chaos that we are now
enduring
you know i would like to say that maybe
this is some kind of small awakening
moment for democrat mayors across
the country she's not the only one
trying to get the schools open and
teachers unions are are
are refusing they're they don't want to
they don't want to work
uh because as we've been talking about
the only the teachers union exists
for the teachers not for the kids
and what that means is that they're
pitting the interests of
the kids against the teachers anytime
the interests of the kids and the
interests of the teachers collide
teachers unions are always going to say
well let's it's it's all about the
teachers
in fact it's not just that they put
teachers above the kids it's just that
the kids are irrelevant
to the teachers union they don't take
into a consideration
education is also irrelevant to the
teacher's union
the only thing the teachers union cares
about why they exist is just to get more
perks and advantages
for the teachers and anything they can
get they'll take
that's all that matters to them so i
would like to say that this is an
awakening moment maybe
maybe a small little red pill moment for
some democrat mayors where they're
realizing that oh gee
the teachers union they're sort of a
cancer on the education system
maybe we shouldn't have this really
powerful organization in the education
system
that is uh that that does this that this
dis discards disregards the interests of
of kids and education maybe this is a
bad thing i would like to say that but
we all know
that um this lesson that mayor lightfoot
and others are learning
will not be will not last long once once
we get past this
however long it takes if it takes 10
years eventually
they're going to go right back into um
into propping up the teachers unit again
unfortunately number three jen saki at
the white house press conference
reiterated something that we've we've
been hearing more and more recently
uh and that some of us predicted long
ago but let's
listen uh what we're also trying to do
is make our health and medical experts
available
to ensure people understand and i'll
reiterate it here today
it's not just a vaccine as obviously an
incredible medical breakthrough
and we want every american to have one
but even after that vaccinated
social distancing wearing masks are
going to be essential and
we'll need to continue communicating
about that through health and medical
experts
if you want people to actually get
vaccinated if you believe in the
vaccination
and you want people to get vaccinated
and you want this to end
okay if all those things apply to you
which the white house
joe biden jens hockey would say that it
does then this is the worst
possible message that you could possibly
have
all you're doing is discouraging people
for getting the vaccination
because what you're telling people what
you're implying anyway i mean the
message people will take from this is
that oh well apparently the vaccine
doesn't really do much you're saying my
lifestyle is not going to change at all
i have to take all the same precautions
and what
why am i getting the vaccine exactly
either the vaccine
is effective or it isn't if it's
effective then i shouldn't need the mass
and i shouldn't need a socially distance
and in fact this this is the reason i'm
guessing
like 90 of the people especially those
who are not elderly and who do not have
uh
uh pre-existing conditions 90 of those
or more
that are going off to get the vaccine or
who will get the vaccine in the future
it's the thing that's going to motivate
them is this idea they can get back to
normal once they have it if you're
taking that away
then people aren't going to get
vaccinated and when you have trouble
getting people vaccinated that's your
fault for that message
so the truth though why why are they
saying this
i think there's two reasons number one
it's just it
people in power like having it
i mean no it's the same old story and
they're not gonna they're not gonna
relinquish it easy they they like having
it
people in positions of power they can
they can they can control what we wear
on our faces they can tell us how close
we can be to other human beings
they like that power they do they're
never going to admit it but they enjoy
it
and so they're clinging on to that and
also at another level
they just don't trust us as the american
people
so the problem from their perspective
probably
is that if they say well uh okay you get
the vaccine and then you know you really
don't need the mask anymore because the
vaccine works
right um if they say that
well then how are they gonna know right
if you're going into stores how to mask
how are they going to know whether you
got the vaccine or not
i mean maybe they give out vaccine cards
or something but they're not sure if
people will go along with that they
don't want to go that far
so the next solution is just to have
everyone wear a mask whether whether
they they want it or not
because that's that's what this has been
about all along
many of these regulations and everything
it's just because they think we're
stupid
and reckless and basically suicidal and
so they have to treat us that way
and that's how they've been approaching
this pandemic from day one
treating us like absolute children and
morons
and the the unfortunate thing is that a
lot of people are perfectly okay with
that
perfectly okay with being treated that
way number four from the daily wire usa
today's sports columnist says that um
nfl superstar quarterback tom brady
eluded criticism over his support for
former president donald trump
because of white privilege in a piece
published tuesday headline tom brady has
gotten an undeserved pass for his past
support
of donald trump nancy armour said the
tampa bay buccaneers qb shouldn't get a
pass just because he's a star
she wrote how mighty white of him
brady's ability to enter and exit the
debate at his choosing to shield himself
from accountability is the height of
white privilege
as this country grapples with the far
reaches of systemic racism
look no further than brady for whom the
expectations and allowances granted
will always be different this uh you
keep hearing this point
it is so unbelievably stupid on so many
levels we covered it in the daily
cancellation
at least the comparison with tom brady
and kaepernick oh why does kaepernick
not have a job but tom brady does well
tom brady is the greatest quarterback in
nfl history bar none there's no debate
about it anymore
and colin kaepernick well sucks and so
that's why he doesn't have
and on top of that he's also a huge
headache and he's got the circus act
that he brings along with him and
there's just
no good reason if you own a team or if
you're a general manager why would you
want
a second or third string caliber guy
who's gonna bring a lot of unwanted
negative attention
and probably accuse you of racism when
you don't start him why would you want
him on your team you wouldn't
why would you want tom brady on your
team well again because he's won six
super bowls he's the greatest
quarterback in history okay
pretty simple there but this claim is
like trying to make tom brady into this
guy's political guy when has tom brady
made any political statement through his
own career his whole career what
this this thing about him being a trump
supporter
that is based on the fact that like five
years ago
he had a maga hat in his locker he
didn't call attention to it
he didn't put it on and say everybody
look i'm a trump supporter he just had
it there
and camera spotted it and this is being
called a political statement
and it's being compared to the
statements of colin kaepernick
who protested during a game and during
the anthem
we're going to compare those two things
give me a break
tom brady has been very consistently
apolitical through his whole career
now so it's not that tom brady is
dipping in and out of
political conversations at will and he's
able to do that because of white
privilege
do you know someone a star athlete who's
able to do that
what what tom brady is accused of um
she says enter and exit the debate at
his choosing you know who's doing that
lebron james not a white guy
lebron james he can massive star athlete
um
and he can enter into a political debate
say a bunch of incendiary inflammatory
things
throw a lob a couple of rhetorical
grenades into an already chaotic
situation
and then just step out and go about his
day and he plays and you know he's going
to be starring in space jam he gets the
he gets
all you know the hollywood jobs he's got
he's got shows on i think hbo or netflix
uh very marketable celebrity an athlete
and he is able to do that
while also being at times intensely
political
and in very unhelpful and inflammatory
ways
that's not tom brady that's lebron james
number five a defendant in florida um
i don't know maybe you gotta respect
this the defendant in florida tried to
make a move on the judge during his bond
hearing
and uh bold move let's see if it paid
off
demetrius lewis on page 26
[Music]
all right i'm good sir how are you
george you is so
gorgeous i just have to tell you you're
gorgeous
thank you mr lewis all right all right
mr lewis vladimir will get you
everywhere
but maybe not here flatter will get you
everywhere but maybe not here
uh i mean you gotta you gotta respect it
maybe maybe maybe maybe you do maybe you
don't
but i i saw that and it remind in some
ways it reminded me of
a video this is from a few years ago but
unfortunately there are many people who
have never had the pleasure of seeing
this
and that uh that came to my attention
recently it's been one of my favorite
videos for a long time many people have
never seen this
it's similar now this okay so that guy
he's sitting on the judge
uh during the bond hearing he's making
it he's you know he's making it
an attempt um there was a guy a few
years ago
this is during the sentencing hearing
and i think he was
he was arrested he was charged convicted
of false imprisonment and a number of
other felonies and he tries
actually serenading the judge
during the sentencing hearing and if
you've never seen or heard this before
well you're in for a treat let's uh
let's watch
that's all wrote a song
hello there you are
i know i wanna say hello this is based
on adele
this is this is when the hello
and i try and be stronger
in this life i chose but i want you to
know
notice how no one's laughing in the
background close
in your honor i'm sorry how is nobody
laughing sorry sorry
to my mother i'm sorry everyone's just
like
does this happen all the time is this a
common occurrence to the victim i'm
sorry sorry
i'm sorry false imprisonment kidnap
somebody he's saying i'm sorry yes your
honor i'm sorry sorry sorry
everyone's just business as usual
thank you your honor there you go now
that guy
got 17 years in prison so um the song
i don't know i guess the judge was not
an adele fan should have chosen
maybe a different pop song to to go with
you know that we talked yesterday about
uh
about people are indoctrinated by disney
movies and we've seen way too many
disney movies growing up brainwashed by
them so we think we can anthropomorphize
animals
a similar thing here maybe this guy has
seen too many musicals
and so he watches the musicals and he
sees how someone can get themselves out
of a bind
by just singing a song
expressing their feelings and that's
enough and he tried it here and uh
fortunately it doesn't work in real life
no i don't
i don't know a lot about style but one
thing i do know is that a really good
looking watch
can put an outfit together it's
sometimes the last
little piece you need that's going to
tie everything together
and that's why i love vincero coming off
the heels of some brand new product
releases ventura watches is here to tell
you that the perfect time to get that
perfect gift
for yourself or somebody else is right
now their their valentine's day special
is officially active for all my
listeners
um visit vincerowatches.com if you're
looking to upgrade your look or better
yet upgrade the look of that special
someone that deserves a well thought out
gift now is your chance to get it on
sale
don't believe look if you're married if
you're in any kind of relationship
don't believe anyone who says they don't
want the gift for valentine's day
because they
everybody wants a gift when it comes
down to it for any occasion so make sure
you get them the gift
venturawatchers.com finding a watch
that's
this good looking built to last can you
know oftentimes costs way too much way
too much money
and you deserve better than settling for
something that's underwhelming
or having to spend way more money than
you need to that's the mistake a lot of
people make with watches head over to
venturawatches.com walsh and take
advantage
of this special discount while you shop
it's important shop now because they
have new color releases for the new year
and they sell out fast especially during
this time of year so you got to go right
now
and also with the new year they're
offering a five-year warranty and a
365-day
return policy all of this stuff you can
you can get this right now but you've
got to go
right now the deal is really too good to
pass up get access to their valentine's
day sale right now go to
venturawatches.com forward slash walsh
that's v
i n c e r o watches dot com forward
slash walsh and the discount will be
auto applied at checkout it's that
simple
do not pay full price on these beautiful
timepieces go to my link and check out
these awesome timepieces now all right
we're going to move on to our
new segment reading the comments the
youtube comments uh a couple comments
from yesterday were worth noting
if i can find them here we go here we go
a rogue addict
says in reference to that bat story
though we talked about yesterday
you know the flightless arthritic bat
who's
whose caretakers are flying it around
even though it can't fly it doesn't know
any better because it's blind
and i said the most merciful thing with
an animal like this is even though it's
very cute and heartwarming to keep them
alive
uh the most merciful thing is to just
put them down right when you when the
animal cannot perform it's
it's a basic function like fly or walk
whether it's a dog or a bat you put them
down that's the most merciful thing
rogue addict says using your logic
should we also
kill the vets that came back without
limbs or with the ptsd
they are also far from happy and they
are in pain i heard this from a lot of
people when i made that point
and this is why it always somehow
manages to surprise me each time
when i have to clarify something here
and that is that people aren't
bats okay that's the difference no i'm
not in favor of killing
people who are say crippled or uh
or blind i'm not in favor of that
that's because they're people
and people are more important than bats
people are more important than animals
people are more important than
your dog who you love so much every
person on earth is more important than
your dog
and we all know that but we pretend not
to
we all know that which is why when
you're driving down the road
and you see a dead raccoon or a dead
deer on the side of the road
you don't think anything of it you don't
pull over you don't you don't start
crying you know
oh my oh my god what happened you don't
do that
now if you were driving by and you saw a
dead person on the side of the road
you're going to react very differently
to that aren't you
why is that because people are more
important have more value
than animals for some reason when you
say it out loud it's scandalous to
people
it's one of those things that everyone
thinks
even the people at peta think it that's
why they kill
animals in their shelters all the time
all right rogue addict not good
um steve a says our local hardware store
says masks are optional
business is booming people are smart
they know who's at risk and who isn't
the fake outrage from that jackass on
msnbc is more disgusting
that is a cnbc not msnbc okay don't um
is more disgusting than the filthy rags
people are covering their face with and
that is what it comes down to is people
just don't
you know the the message
if we had um leaders who respected us
the message from the very beginning
would have been just be smart
uh be careful you know
and if you're if you're at a particular
risk of of covid then you know
you you want to take even more
precautions maybe than someone who isn't
and so we're not going to have the same
not everyone's going to be doing exactly
the same thing not everyone has to lock
themselves in their home
not everyone is at the same risk level
not everyone is at the same risk of
of of um being severely affected by
covenant not everyone's at the same risk
of spreading it either
don hathaway says your decision to forgo
using a private jet to help save the
planet has inspired me to do the same if
ever i get the chance to own a
lamborghini i pledge to never drive it
thank you for setting the bar so high
and thank you don
these are things we're all we all you
know we often do our part i'm not flying
a private jet you're not driving a
lamborghini we're all doing our part
uh elaine says matt walsh channeling
boondock saints
and then she quotes they all just
watched as kitty was being stabbed to
death in broad daylight they watched as
her assailant walked away now we must we
now we must all fear evil men but
there's another kind of evil which we
must fear most and that is the
indifference of good men
uh yeah good quote there and boondock
saints of course i'm a child of the 90s
so i
i love that movie when i was a teenager
i haven't gone back and watched it again
because it's one of those movies that i
suspect if i watched again as an adult
it wouldn't hold up although i don't
know i'm just going to let it be you
know in my memories as a great movie
um but i actually i disagree see it's
not the indifference of good men that we
have to worry about in society because
good men by definition are not
indifferent
if you're if you're a good man or a good
woman then you have virtue and virtue is
not indifferent
virtue is is an active present thing
virtue is something that you're doing
every day
um virtues like uh uh like courage and
humility
and mercy these are things that we do so
no it's not the indifference of good men
we have to worry about because that's
kind of a misnomer it's a contradiction
in terms
uh it's the indifference of bad people
and i would submit that the the primary
or at least the most
um harmful form of
badness in our culture today is
indifference
it's not it's not hate per se yeah there
are a lot of hateful people but those
aren't really the people we got to worry
about the most
it's just the empty indifferent people
who maybe don't care you know they don't
hate their fellow man
they just don't care about their fellow
man at all makes no difference to them
that's what we have to worry about
finally scott says matt stop showing
your biceps
i want to be able to actually listen to
you well scott
out of respect for you i have worn long
sleeves today um
you know i would never want to cause
i'm a christian i would never want to
cause my brother in christ to stumble so
i'm looking out for you protecting your
heart as they say
well you know it's february and not a
lot going on in february not a lot to
write home about besides
groundhog day you know how i feel about
that valentine's day you know how i feel
about that
uh the super bowl i mean that's one
thing at least but here's the big thing
about february um
it is now it's being dubbed febru
harry that's right happy february harry
everyone
uh for me ev it's you know there's also
janu harry
june harry all the months are hairy for
me but now's the time
for you to get a little hairy grow a
beard but please
do yourself a favor do all of us a favor
because we have to look at your ugly mug
so do us do us a favor and and do it in
style beard supply is running a promo
right now on all of their beard oils
buy one get a second one 50 off uh
no promo code necessary just head on
over to beersupply.com to get the
discount today
i get asked all the time how i managed
to have such a glorious
well-kept uh beard
that just elevates my own looks so much
and one of the one of the secrets i tell
people this is true beard oil
uh you know you can't just grow the
beard and leave it you got to take care
of the beard
nurture the beard beard oil not only
moisturizes moisturizes away the itch so
that you feel
better while you're wearing it uh it's
also nourishes your hair
for a better looking beard overall and
this is something that you need to do so
grab one today get a second one 50
off knowing these oils are all natural
and all awesome for your whiskers
whether those whiskers be old or new
whatever the case may be
this is what you got to do visit
beardsupply.com to get the promo code
today
that's beardsupply.com and also
you know this is it people this is your
chance to get 25 off a new daily wire
membership with code rhf
and it's fading fast so sign up today to
watch our new feature film
run hide fight you've been hearing us
talk about it for for weeks now if
you've waited if you procrastinated
this whole time then um don't miss your
chance to get that 25
off that is as my dad would always say
that's pennywise and pound foolish
so make sure you go right now
dailywire.com get the 25 off deal
and um you also get to watch this this
movie that
um is just thoroughly entertaining very
suspenseful and
as we've told you people love it 93
rating from the audience
and they're not going to lie to you 27
rating from the critics it's even gone
up it used to be like 14
so even the critics are warming to it a
little bit but not that much but who
cares what they think
i care what the audience thinks and the
audience loves it this is your last
chance okay use promo code rhf to get 25
off your membership at dailywire.com and
join us today in this cultural fight
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
now today for our daily cancellation
let's look at two stories that are
happening at the same time
first morgan wallen is watching his
career implode before his eyes as a
consequence of a video that catches the
country star
country music star using a racial slur
now wallin and his buddies were laughing
and carrying on after returning home
from a night of drinking this past
weekend and their antics were so loud
and disruptive that they woke up the
neighbors
one of whom decided to pull out a phone
and document
the commotion unfortunately for wallen
the camera had been turned on right
before he shouted to one of his friends
across the street presumably referring
to another friend who was in perhaps
an especially drunken state he said take
care of this
blank n-word here's uh here's the video
take care
[Music]
okay so i just i wanted you to
to see or hear that just to get the tone
of it
um it's clear that wallen used the word
he should not have used it's also clear
that he didn't mean for it to be public
though he did shout it in the street
which is not a good way of keeping
things private
and he meant it as a joke okay
nonetheless as expected the penalties
have been quite significant while
apologized profusely but that didn't
stop the inevitable from happening his
record label suspended him the academy
of country music awards
revoked his eligibility cumulus media
iheart media and siriusxm pulled all of
his songs from their stations
effectively removing him from the radio
altogether
okay this is the swiftest and harshest
backlash we have probably seen against a
star
a star musician in i don't know how long
years
at least even though star musicians do
and say objectionable things all the
time
while wallen's star is rapidly
plummeting after saying one offensive
thing a thing which if context matters
was said drunkenly and ingest
another star is ascending again after a
minor and temporary dip
the juxtaposition here i think is quite
instructive nick cannon
and viacom cbs have reunited and are
feeling so good
and the production of his vh1 series
wilden out will resume following a brief
suspension
of their relationship following comments
that canon made on his podcast last
summer
um now you might remember what provoked
the backlash was canon's claim
that black people can't be anti-semitic
because they are they are the semitic
people and they are quote the true
hebrews
this is what prompted the brief severing
of ties with viacom cbs
and an apology from canon and but that's
all water under the bridge now
apparently canon's career is back and
it's on track and he's rolling again
no problem but the true hebrew stuff
wasn't close to the worst thing he said
during the podcast
the the really offensive and racist
remarks were never acknowledged by the
media or by canon himself or even by
viacom cbs when they initially condemned
his statements
they just ignored this part canada in
fact has faced no consequence
not even a temporary consequence for his
actual racist diatribe in which he
claimed
that white people fear black quote
unquote
and have a quote lack of compassion
because of their melanin deficiency
and if that wasn't enough he also said
that white people are quote a little
less
read inferior to black people and that
because they don't have
the power of the sun they behave quote
out of fear out of low self-esteem
and out of deficiency and can quote only
act
evil robbing and raping in order to
survive he says
white people can and says are quote
closer to animals and are quote the true
savages
okay that's these are all things that he
said um this
is by far in a way the most racist thing
that any celebrity of his stature has
said
in many years if you've got a if you've
got a more racist thing than let me know
and he never apologized for it and he
never now he has his job back
so let's stack these two situations up
against each other wallen
used a racial slur in a non-racial
context
was drunk and joking and never meant for
it to be recorded
canon on the other hand expressed his
true feelings about white people
with thorough detail and did so publicly
and proudly his opinion as he says
himself
is that white people are subhuman
animalistic savages
and are inferior to him so who's
committed the greater sin here
who suffered the worst consequence
objectively there is little doubt that
wallen is the lesser offender
also the lesser human by nick cannon's
way of thinking and even less doubt that
he has endured the more severe
professional consequences
he's also the only one between the two
of them who apologized
so talking about privilege as we were
earlier who has the real privilege here
the man who said a bad thing apologized
and lost his career anyway
or the man who said a worse thing didn't
apologize
and got his career back you cannot say
that the first man has all the privilege
without removing all meaning from the
word privilege
so is it enough then in that case to say
that white privilege is a myth
but black privilege is real is that what
i'm
getting to here no not quite because if
it were as simple as that
then candace owens not only black but a
woman as well
would enjoy all of nick cannon's
privilege and then some
but that's clearly not the case so
rather than black or white privilege
it's probably more accurate to speak of
identity privilege or more
accurately tribal privilege your
privilege is tied to your tribe
and within the privileged tribe the
pecking order is determined by a
complicated and convoluted hierarchy of
identities
nick cannon can survive and thrive in
spite of his insanely racist views or
even partly because of them maybe
um do first and foremost to his leftism
okay now if canon were a conservative an
acolyte of
you know thomas soul instead of louis
farrakhan
there would be no redemption arc for him
but within that leftist tribe which
affords him power and prestige to begin
with
he earns his rank according to his
racial and sexual identity
though the privilege of his tribe so
through the privilege of his tribe
and by its own internal rules he can say
pretty much whatever he wants about race
but he's not at the very top of the
intersectional heap so if
so if instead of white people he had
labeled say
gay people or transgenders or women
as quote a little less then he'd be
banished from polite society
with all the same speed and vigor that
has been directed at morgan wallin
now as for morgan wallen he's white
a country singer and he lives in
nashville which makes him for all
intents and purposes anyway a
conservative or at least conservative
adjacent
he is the wrong race and in the wrong
tribe
the only privilege he has then is the
kind he can buy with all his wealth
and that'll probably be enough to keep
him comfortable for a while but not
enough to save his career or his
reputation
and this is privilege this is how
privilege
this is nick cannon shows exactly how
privilege works
it's kind of confusing it's a tangled
web indeed
but this is the way it goes and this is
why the concept of white privilege
is canceled and nick cannon is cancelled
by me anyway if not by anybody else for
whatever that's worth which is
unfortunately
nothing at all we'll leave it there for
today thanks for watching everybody
thanks for listening have a great
weekend
talk to you on monday godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel ledoski the
show is edited by danny d'amico
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 21. hey
everybody this is andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets started so come on over to the
andrew clavin show and laugh your way
through the fall of the republic with me
andrew clavin